[Music]
lots of people who have tried before us
had failed and all of their aircraft are
scattered across the ice cap
you ready oh yeah when thinking about
flying a tiny helicopter across the
North Atlantic the answer is no way too
dangerous
absolutely not Sandra are we good to go
but we're going to go for it so I've got
a company it's called five fly we have
airplanes and helicopters that we loaded
up with instruments and gear to go out
collect information bring it back to
people so that they can do good
[Music]
the goal was to take this new helicopter
we thought bring it from London all the
way to San Diego
and planning for this trip Greenland was
totally mysterious that was the unknown
to me which was the most attractive part
there's no footage of this area because
it's really hard to get to coming down
that shoreline was just absolutely
fantastic you can see for what seems to
be a hundreds of miles and there are
these icebergs just everywhere
Greenland is a huge cap of ice and the
ice cap comes down to the shoreline
where it starts to break apart in the
form of these glaciers and that's where
we were flying along and you can see the
glaciers falling apart right on the
ocean's surface and you just can't help
but wonder how is this huge environment
changing all I had to do is look down
and you can see the place melting and
it's melting fast as Greenland melts you
have to wonder where is all this water
going and it's going right into the
ocean I mean this waterfall that we saw
was just absolutely massive and it's
just pouring water right off the glacier
into the ocean flying along watching the
water from these melt pools disappear
down a hole sending all this heat to the
bottom of Greenland has to make you
wonder you know is this a disappearing
landscape
[Music]
these glaciers are literally crumbling
behind us right now we are on the front
lines of climate change
[Music]
we captured this type of imagery so that
we can help inspire the people that are
in charge of this planet and it's not
just politicians it's people like you
and I that put gas in our cars that turn
on the light bulb that build houses that
make these huge infrastructures it's
important to understand how this affects
places that we've never been
[Music]
to just come here and in one day make a
huge assessment of what the planet is
doing is just wrong but it does take
your breath away when you're here and
you see it for yourself
I can't tell you how absolutely exciting
it is to be able to go to a place
survive it fill our cameras with footage
that has never been seen and bring it
back to the world to be able to share
with you a place that is absolutely
remarkable and special
[Music]
you
[Music]